[Music]
guys like this only have three options
value life in prison or we start talking
so laughs kick why I want my kids to be
around us she lookin at ya we don't
tolerate stupidity got that yeah one the
ear of crap someone who I you got one
year ago
it was your first phone Fred gave to me
needs will be a ioin I think ro family I
don't make you [ __ ] ever man now listen
talk to me Babs do you know what about
you they go like it you better known as
racist I don't know what to do
in this business you've got to stay
focused or follow right down the rabbit
hole what if I take all this stuff off
and I'm still a piece of [ __ ]
you have an outright don't answer your
phone
don't show up in meetings anymore I
don't even know if you remember I don't
know what they're gonna do you need to
get the kids I got here it's time for
you to come back home now you have no
choice
you're still breathing because I am
never ancient incan
is it true desi said that you're an evil
man